we have this ancient drive to forage for
information and technology have sort of
shifted the balance that we now just
switch so rapidly that if fragments our
attention if you look at perceptual
abilities decision-making memory
emotional regulation all of these
capacities are diminished when they're
fragmented teachers don't even know if
you ask them about their classrooms who
has the best working memory
who is the best sustained attention who
is the best emotional regulation where's
the best compassion they don't know the
answers to any of these questions they
know the reading and math performance
and that is that is a tragedy in my mind
we can use this closed-loop experience
to improve abilities of the mind to a
level that we could Knob not achieve
with any molecule because we don't have
the targeting or the personalization
this is our a AI vision as I always say
AI for H AI artificial intelligence for
human intelligence that's where I think
these types of algorithms should go how
many of you have seen a talk featuring
Adam gazelle we have knew you've read
the book the distracted mind how many of
you have seen some talks or read the
book okay cool okay
like half of you great so for those that
don't know Adam gazelle II is world
renowned neuroscientist author speaker
the man behind neuro scape behind
Achille behind jazz partners behind
since thinks so much there's so many
things that Adams doing but it's all in
the field of neuroscience and technology
and enhancing human intelligence and
human well-being so without further ado
let's jump into the conversation with
Adam whoo
thank you thank you thank you for
joining us I'm really excited at him
I'm impressed with so many people on a
Friday and I would come out to talk
about this so thanks for being here I
appreciate that and how many of you been
to First Fridays Adams gatherings yeah
that's cool yeah okay so Adam also hosts
these gatherings i displace on the first
Friday of every month for a hundred
almost a hundred of them now 10 years 92
92 of them so 10 years of these
gatherings and it's just a melting pot
of multidisciplinary minds which is
awesome because then that's how really
strong connections and ideas and and an
execution happens in many ways and I
love that and it's a big inspiration for
me that you that you do that so Adam how
long now has it been that you've been
studying the brain it's been two Dec
over two decades yeah so I started I
guess in 1990 so yeah yeah you're
approaching it a while third one yeah
wow that's a long time to be studying
the brain there's and this is an
incredible I don't know how we process
the stimuli and how we live and how we
evolve to get to this point it's it's a
beautiful beautiful thing that we've
gotten here tell us about the evolution
of the mind to start because however
this beautiful thing manifested its way
up through four billion years of
evolution up as this pinnacle on earth
is just gorgeous and now we're building
civilization and our tichel intelligence
is so much more sure okay let's start at
the beginning we have a whole night in
front of us well you know what one of my
interests when you know speaking about
neuroscience and writing about it which
I do in this book a bit is just to take
a step back and think about why we have
brains at all because when you view it
from an evolutionary perspective I think
you get some really fresh insights on
why we have challenges in our daily
lives which we all do in our own ways
and especially related to technology I
think that's
really important and timely topic so you
know if you think about the brain before
there was a brain we had this need as
single-celled organism so all the way
back in our evolutionary past to survive
right and our survival was dictated
essentially by two features two elements
of how we interacted with our
environment how we could sense our
environment and how we could respond to
that sensation so we did that in order
to get nutrients and in order to avoid
threats and when I say we I'm speaking
about organisms that didn't even have a
brain just single-cell so they're
basically sensing chemicals that they
need to survive or they need to avoid
and then they move in response to that
that cycle of sensing and moving really
set up for the entire evolutionary
future in front of it which was
eventually multicellular organisms and
eventually the brain our ability to
sense our environment and respond to it
in many ways that's pretty much what our
brain does almost completely as that as
we evolved sensation which is a very
sort of rudimentary ability to detect
the world around you became more
complicated and became what we call
perception perception is an
interpretation of how we sense the world
basically defines our entire reality but
we don't just sense the world we then
respond to it we call that action where
our behaviors come in this cycle the
perception action cycle is part of every
creature creatures brain including our
own it is even anatomically localized
where you perceive from the middle of
your brain back from your sensory area
your visual cortex your auditory cortex
and then your motor cortex and forward
is the motion the output the action and
so this cycle of responding to your
environment by sensing it and then
moving is really the core of how our
brains work it always has worked and
it's a it's a good perspective because
we haven't abandoned those aspects of
our brains it's a matter of fact it's
still largely how we interact with our
world
is by sensing and responding to it often
very reflexively now lower order animals
and if you look in our in our past
basically we received information and
then without any ado we responded to it
right these reflexive cycles are what
allowed us to survive I would say the
most important and unique part of the
human brain and brain evolution is that
we've created a pause between sensing
and responding and in that pause which
exists to more or less success as we'll
talk about there's the ability to judge
and to make decisions and then to have
goals that you carry out and you can
even resist a very strong reflexive
response and decide not to have that
sort of innate reaction that you're
programmed to have but have a different
response and other animals do not do
that very much at all if you look across
some of our closest relatives and
dolphins and other animals you see that
behavior but it still might have the
pause they have a they have minimal
pause some animals you do see inserting
a little bit of that but it's very
minimal most of their behaviors are
really dictated in very reflexive
responses to their environment and Adam
are we running like simulations of the
potentials well a lot of what the human
brain does is really live a little bit
in the future we have this predictive
machinery that allows us to so fluidly
interact in the world a lot of that
makes us even less flexible in how we
react then we might think that we are
doing but in either case this is this
ability to pause even if it's momentary
to reappraise the information that
you're getting to then interpret it and
then respond with the goal is what makes
us so amazing it's what allowed us
humans to build the cultures and
societies that we've created to have
language and art and music and all of
the technology that surrounds us all of
this is potential because we basically
unshackled the
the chains that make most creature
slaves to their environment and don't
allow them to break free in the way that
we have so with that has come you know
the glory of being human and all the the
things that we've created and a real
deep sense of consciousness and identity
but there's also been a lot of burden
with that very unique human burden with
the stresses and the depression and many
of the challenges that go with those
thinking processes that live in that
pause so that's a like sort of my you
know my perspective on evolution and
when you think about it from that way
and then you and take a look at what's
going on around us and many many
different respects not the least of
which is modern-day technology it really
helps give shed a light on why we are so
challenged by modern tech this is why I
love Adam because he can go through this
elaborate way of explaining the truth of
how all creatures cents and then we have
now evolved a deeper sort of perception
enabling us to pause putting us up
co-operate language technology now etc
with civilizations evolving I love the
way that you can go through that span of
evolution with us now you you've taught
me through the book and through your
talks about the idea of foraging I love
this idea foraging it you know thousands
of years ago food foraging food forging
even even more tens of thousands risco
and now it's information foraging
information foraging but now it's a
firehose that's just everything is just
undo you turn it off and etc this is a
lot of what we see as a problem today
this is what you write in your piece
about the cognition crisis and kind of
what's going on with it so walk us
through kind of the foraging now and
okay this is yet another complex
discussion but it works better with
slides it's there's some figures in it
in the book that I could refer you to
but I'll give just just a basic overview
sort of when I when I wrote this book
the distracted mine and the subtitles
ancient brains
high-tech world I became very intrigued
with it I just didn't want to write
another self-help book I'm not like a
self-help guru at all
you know I'm figuring out like everyone
else but I you know I wanted to not just
like list things that make sense but
didn't have any foundation or any
backing and you know there's just not a
lot of data on some of the approaches
the practical approaches that you can do
to deal with a distracted mind and so I
wanted to have a framework in order to
give that advice not just for other
people but for even myself trying to
manage it all and so one of the things
that I was struck with when I was
thinking about this and I wrote a lot of
this book in other countries when I was
traveling giving talks and something
about being on the road and in you know
foreign locations that could sort of
free your mind from your regular
thinking process and one thing that I
sort of had a game with with myself with
thinking about what parts of our brain
our most ancient and that are still part
of our lives whether we recognize them
or not and then how does those aspects
of our brains that are preserved how are
they uniquely challenged by the modern
world that was sort of my my thinking
process that I never really read about
but I sort of went through as an
exercise so I'll talk about foraging for
a moment but one one aspect that just
connects with what I just told you about
evolution is this aspect of being
stimulated by the environment and making
decisions reflexively on that you know
in my field in cognitive science we call
that bottom-up information it's how the
environment imposes itself upon you
making decisions right if there is a
flash of light a loud sound your name
also will do it you will pay attention
independent of your goals you'll be
pulled to it bottom-up reflexively you
know we still we still have these right
bottom-up stimuli that drive a response
without our goals right we're full of
them we couldn't walk without them we
were it's still embedded in us in many
ways so a safety mechanism of course I
mean if it's it was what enabled
to survive is that you smell a predator
and you flee right these are just
reflexes that lead to survival we're
still we still have them if we didn't
we'd be in a lot of trouble but what we
have in addition to bottom up is top
down which is this ability that I said
to have goals we're in a constant sort
of struggle I mean a more positive way
of thinking about it as an integration
between bottom-up and top-down we do it
constantly we're constantly dealing with
the environment sort of imposing itself
upon us and demanding it us to do
certain things and then us making
decisions either for or against it and
so this is another ancient part of our
brains that exists there's in the book I
wrote about what one thing that just
blew me away
because I lived through it probably a
lot of you are watching the news when we
had the giant tsunami that killed like
300,000 people very few animals died in
that tsunami it's really fascinating
whoa almost all of the animals ran into
the hills well most of the humans ran
onto the beach this is like a top-down
bottom-up issue right because when the
ocean recedes like that that's like a
very clear side at least it was to every
animal and bird and elephant in the in
these in these countries that this is
really bad and we should run away but
humans because of our top-down curiosity
thought maybe we should explore and it
was a bad idea right and it's it's it's
it's an example of what the human brain
has done and that I said is like sort of
an asset and a burden and so before you
know so I'll tell you about the forging
thing but I do want to impress upon you
to start paying attention to these two
competing aspects of your attention your
goal-directed attention and the
environment driven attention and watch
how many decisions you make that may not
be based on your goals that may not even
be in your best interests the technology
story is very much about this as we know
our tech technology companies and I'm
not saying that there's any malice here
but they certainly have figured out ways
to use bottom-up stimuli very
effectively
you know the buzzes the flashes of
it's the the vibrations these are really
strong bottom-up stimuli that you
respond to and part of what I think is
going on is this thing more rapid sort
of activation by bottom-up information
that maybe makes us even less top-down
and just makes us more responsive to
stimuli so that's one aspect of the
ancient brain but despite the fact that
you may know this right even hearing
this we still do this and we especially
children they seek out information in
you know a hungry way oh I feel it in
myself right you could if you're enough
quiet moment maybe that quiet moment is
just like 10 seconds at a red light
you're like you know what's going on
here right you just you're trying to
seek out information and so I was really
fascinated with this phenomena that
everyone knows about and in my readings
I found data showing that other primates
like monkeys when you do experiments
looking at the reward system that shows
that primates in particular are driven
for information rewards using in very
much the same systems that drove other
animals to seek food and juice rewards
even though it's not like critical for
survival information alone triggers the
same ancient reward mechanisms and so
from that perspective you could think of
us you know and then you add the
variability to the rewards and it gets
even more and also those rewards could
could you know have very extrinsic
factors that drive them they can be very
frequent but we seek out information in
much the same ways from my perspective
that other animals seek out food and so
from that if you think about it that way
and I think the data suggest that that
is a reasonable hypothesis then I became
interested in if we can explain human
behavior by looking at animal behavior
when it comes to animals foraging food
fortunately there's a very sophisticated
school of thought
related to this mathematically worked
out called optimal foraging theories
there are many of them animals forage
and interact with their food in very
different ways so there's very complex
mathematical relations related to
predators and prey there's also some
really beautiful theory theories one
called the marginal value theorem which
describes animals that forage for food
in what's known as a chi environments
many animals do this take a squirrel
right a squirrel in a tree if you've
ever heard my talk sites sometimes give
this example a squirrel in a tree is
foraging for food and at some point that
squirrel will make a decision a
subconscious decision to leave that tree
and go to another tree and
mathematically you could describe and
this has been well described and shown
to very accurately predict behavior of
animals both in laboratory and the wild
what are the factors that leads an
animal to leave a patch and go to
another patch and it's really related to
two sides of this axis one are the
benefits of remaining in that patch
which is how many nuts are in that tree
now the benefits have a diminishing
return as they eat them it's getting
less and less and less the other side of
the curve is the cost of getting to the
next tree yeah if that makes trees a
mile away that squirrel will finish
those nuts in that tree if that tree is
closer they'll make the decision to
leave earlier so it's sort of a
cost-benefit ratio the idea that I had
is that an are trees are in all right
next to each exactly well that's what's
changed so we forage for information
like other animals forage for food so if
you think about it our information is in
patches as well that patch might be your
phone or a website there's a density of
it with sparse areas in between so we
make decisions about when you leave that
website when do you leave that
conversation those are our information
patches and I'd say we have the same
subconscious decisions of other animals
the benefits of remaining there versus
the opportunity or the cost to get to
the next information patch so if you
think about our behaviors of foraging
information in that way we're driven by
those same elements the idea that I sort
of proposed in this book is
that technology has really put pressure
on both sides of that one site is
incredibly obvious right so the
accessibility as you would just say an
Allen to the next patch has become so
small right that next patch might be
that link in an article that you just
have to touch on it might be that other
tab in a browser that's already open it
might be you know that other screen that
you have there is just so much
accessibility information it is so easy
to get to that other information patch
the other part which is a little more
complicated is on the benefits side of
remaining in a patch so one of the ideas
that the literature supports is that we
humans have become a lot less rewarded
by remaining in a certain place in a
certain information Plateau and there
are really two influences on this one is
anxiety and the other is boredom we have
a very very low tolerance to boredom the
data would show that it's getting lower
and lower so boredom accumulates so
that's sort of like that you know the
squirrel that the nuts are disappearing
for us we're also using up that
information but we also have
accumulating boredom and we also have
anxiety driven by the fear of missing
out FOMO of what's going on in the next
batch as well as performance anxiety
productivity anxiety how many things
could have been doing at the same time
so that's the basic idea in a nutshell
is nutshell is that with legs curls we
are being driven to switch by the
subconscious signals related to our
benefits of remaining and the cost of
getting that to the next one and what
technology has done through both
influencing both the costs and the
benefits is to drive rapid switching and
if you watch especially children use
technology it's not subtle right you
know the data suggests switching every
30 seconds or or more you know thousands
of chickens on on texting and social
media sometimes we've been in a day and
so that's that's the idea in a nutshell
that we have this ancient drive to
forage for information
and technology has sort of shifted the
balance that we now just switch so
rapidly that if fragments our attention
in that time that we have that pause to
see that oh I'm on a bus or I'm doing
something with with time to pause if we
don't grab our phone and go to
information forge that can lead to a lot
of the beautiful default mode network to
the creativity to to see the world and
new and interesting ways we can take
deeper breaths we can find new ways of
the thing that we want to build into the
world
whatever that top-down again I want to
get to that that that top-down goal that
you've set to build something into the
world that pause can give you the time
to think about that goal and think about
it in new ways and go and help yourself
creatively execute that into the world
that's so important so I love I love how
you illustrate the bottom-up vs.
top-down processing and how top-down is
just so crucial I think we see this all
the time with ourselves is that we set
ourselves you know we try and have high
conscientiousness we set our goal and we
want to achieve it and we do the steps
that are needed to get it done and then
there's distractions and distractions
along the way and our tendency to go for
those distractions those short term
rewards versus the long-term ones we
just gained so much more actualization
from the long term and this is becoming
more complex now with the attention
economy you started you know referencing
a little bit well you said no malice but
a lot of people think there is lots of
malice because the eyeballs are the
dollars and let's talk a bit about the
the way that you know the goals are
being able to be set from top down and
the importance of that because that's
like huge on execution and people living
healthy is finding these goals with
their mental health balance and then
also how that relates especially to the
attention economy and what how we're
able to take control of our use of tech
yeah so there's a lot that I'll try to
unpack a little bit of it
when you know so this idea of the
foraging model driving our behaviors is
sort of why we do it even when we know
we don't want to do it we still feel the
pull to do it that's so that's like
really a hypothesis what I described to
you there's actually some papers that
are starting to come back some have been
inspired by this idea in the book to put
data to that but it was really just a
framework to think about if these are
the factors that are stressing us in
this manner this gives us a clue of what
we could start reversing in our lives
and how we can be more strategic about
our interaction with technology so that
we're healthier right because I love
technology I think many of us do I don't
think we're putting that genie back in
the bottle for me it's about being in
control of the technology so to sort of
answer your question if that's the
reason why we do it what are the
consequences of it and the consequences
are dramatic and they pretty much at you
know act on every aspect of both our
cognition and our behaviors so you know
most of my research up until I guess
around 10 years ago when I started doing
the work that we'll talk about a little
bit using technology in a positive way
with studying distraction and multitask
in the laboratory so we have dozens of
papers of participants that were in MRI
scanners or eg so I'm a cognitive
neuroscientist or was now sort of
considered myself more of a
translational neuroscientist my PhD was
actually in molecular neuroscience so
I'm on my third stage of my neuroscience
life but as a cognitive neuroscience
mood study what are the neural
mechanisms that lead to the negative
impact of being distracted or
multitasking that's what the majority of
the work that I did when I started my
professorship at UCSF 12 years ago and
what we find is that when you are
exposed to relevant information that
pulls you away because of its strong
bottom-up you know salience or you
engage in more than one task the neural
networks that we engage to accomplish
something at a high level essentially
are broken and need to be reengage
so we are now really you know convinced
by so you know so many converging
research studies that we do not parallel
process multiple top-down goals at the
same time we it's just not how our
brains work I think you know clearly we
wish they would and we sometimes believe
that we could make them but for the most
part these attention directing networks
the top-down networks engage and then
they need to switch when you redirect
your attention to something else so when
you start fragmenting your attention
because you're switching those patches
rapidly what's happening there is that
you are just losing fidelity of the
information that was being retained and
what we always you know the term that
we'll use in our papers is that you
suffer a cost a switch cost with each
one of these and that cost is often
represented as a slow slowing down of
your abilities or loss of accuracy so
what we see when we do our research is
that if you look at perceptual abilities
decision-making memory emotional
regulation all of these capacities are
diminished in terms of the level that
they could reach when they're fragmented
and then that cascades to deleterious
effects on all of our behaviors that
behavior might be your work performance
if you're a child that might be your
school or your study it might be your
safety on the road driving it might be
the quality of your relationships the
compassion and empathy that you're able
to deliver and share all of these things
are really you know suspect to and and
have the consequences of a breakdown in
cognition so that's to say is it safe to
say this that as we're firing in a
direction of top-down processing on a
task then we switch we activate a
different part of our neural
architecture and it takes you know
you're taking the
the electrical processing that's going
on in that portion of the brain and
transitioning it over to another area of
potentially of the brain yeah it's part
of the cost of switching as well as all
the gold that you are trying to achieve
so the brain really works as a network
system so areas of the brain don't
really work as Islands they work as
networks brain areas have different
functions depending upon the context
that other brain areas are we see this
with neuroimaging so if you have a
network in the brain that's activated to
accomplish a goal which is how the brain
works we literally see those networks
switch they they break down and they
have to be rebuilt and it there's a time
cost to do that that time might be 150
milliseconds right just a little bit
over a tenth of a second I'm not it's
not a long time but it's time and that
time could add up depending on how many
switches there are and when you're doing
something that demands precision that
that cost can become quite you know
quite real yeah okay now you said
something else a little bit ago that was
really interesting but I want to want to
move to how this relates to the
attention economics and today and then I
want to get to how your what you're
doing as solutions for this so tell us a
bit about your thoughts on it's
basically a big land grab that's going
on in the attention economy who can get
the most eyeballs for the longest
periods of time and these are young kids
want to be influencers this is good you
know this is now bigger than it's ever
been with these computers in our pockets
yeah so this is not really my area of
expertise or research but there is
obviously a conflict in many ways
between how the economics of our tech
world especially in places like social
media but other areas of e-commerce work
in terms of demanding your attention in
order to make their money and so your
attention becomes part of the
transaction that leads to advertise
dollars that allows all these sources to
feel like they're free but they're not
really free you're paying through your
attention and so that's really the gist
of the issue that you know many people
are you know paying a lot of attention
to on how we can rework our technology
so that the demands on your attention
are not what actually leads to their
business success so there's that's the
conflict is that what they want is your
attention our attention is already
fragmented and it's very limited as
we've been talking about so in some ways
it's one of your most valuable things
that you own more valuable than the
money in your pockets and so instead of
asking for your money
which you might pay you know your twenty
dollars a month to have social network
access maybe would be worth it for you
to have your attention under your own
control so we have enough challenge
controlling our attention even when we
want to when very smart organizations
are figuring out how to move your
attention for their own economic returns
it gets a lot more complicated so that's
essentially if you hear these terms
about attention economy that's really
what's being discussed is that the model
itself is designed in such a way that it
inflames this problem that I think would
be there anyway just because of the
accessibility of technology but because
decisions are being made to move your
attention in certain places for other
motives it complicates it a lot so some
of us you know like I think the people
in this field there's a lot of fields
here at a lot of eyeballs on it I would
say and we talk I was talking about
someone as the money colleagues yeah I
would say we're allies in this my my
view is that we're not I don't want to
burn this village down I think
technology has done an amazing amount of
things and I'm a big fan but we've made
a lot of mistakes I to me it does I
don't want to belabor whether or not
those mistakes were intentional or just
unwise I feel like we need to assess
where we're at we need a better more
informed understanding of how the brain
works
when we create new technologies we could
do a lot to fix our current system and
we should be doing a lot better going
forward so that's generally my views and
this is what you are doing right now
going forward so let's let's talk
because actually you listed these these
myths you list some of the mental health
issues as well as you started exploring
some of them of when we get too much
into the habit of the ding ding ding
ding dings all of a sudden we're driving
and texting and we're dying and then the
little the kids don't have time to you
know there's so many things that are
going on with the mental health suicide
rates there's a lot of things that are
going on with the mental maybe we could
Pleasant f1 sex so moving on to the
solutions because you mentioned the name
cognition crisis and we didn't really
talk about it all you don't want to
spend a ton of time on it but you did
mention it it was in the title and it's
not the title of this book this book is
already old to me cuz you know by the
time you write a book and then it comes
out it's like old news to me I'm happy
by the the ideas in here but your great
ideas I'm happy with what we did but I
like I don't know if I'm right any more
books I like writing things getting them
out there while they feel fresh so I
wrote a piece earlier this year called
the cognition crisis that I published on
medium the exchanges were much more
timely it was it was a better general
experience for me if you read that piece
it's not that long 18 minutes according
to medium it's it's it's my more recent
thoughts on this topic and just the very
quick you know 2 minute summary is it
sort of extends this idea that we
already just talked about to what's
impossible to ignore especially when you
travel around the world as I have been
is like the world sort of looks very
homogeneous in some ways like the
problems that parents face and the
challenges that children have are really
the same everywhere you know I give
probably on average 70 tops a year
around the world and that's because I'm
invited to speak about the same topic in
all of these countries which to me is
heartening because it makes the world
feel a lot more connected than it seems
if you read the news the world
feels like were the same people we have
the same struggles and the cognition
crisis was my response to that of saying
that we're not doing a great job our
species in terms of evolving our minds
that we you know call the things that
we've just talked about the challenges
that we face we are sitting you know
with half a billion people suffering
debilitating effects of depression and
anxiety and attention deficits and
memory problems and they are getting
worse we see suicide rates increasing
and children especially here but we see
these trends around the world and we
have two systems not even talking about
the tech world now we're talking about
our education system and our medical
system our mental health system these
should be the institutions that were
created to help us have healthier Minds
they're not doing their jobs so I
actually put a lot more negative
attention to those industries rather
than the tech industry I feel that our
education system has largely focused
still from its foundations in the
Industrial Revolution to transfer
information content maybe now in some
more evolved schools skill development
but not really building the underlying
information processing systems of the
brain cognition attention teachers don't
even know if you ask them about their
classrooms who has the best working
memory
who is the best sustained attention who
is the best emotional regulation where's
the best compassion they don't know the
answers to any of these questions they
know the reading and math performance
and that is that is a tragedy in my mind
so we're not assessing it and developing
it in children and then on the mental
health side when you do decide that a
child has an attention problem not
because you assess it just because you
know the bug and the [ __ ] out of you
they go to a doctor you're like oh you
have an attention problem then you give
them a molecule that has a very blunt
effect on their brain often depresses
aspects of their personality and you sit
him back in the classroom and so on both
sides of it from the education side in
the medical side we've been using the
same exact tools for hundreds of years
certainly on the medical side you know
60 years of depending on small molecules
to
complex phenomena related to emotional
regulation and attention and memory and
they have tons of side effects that
poorly targeted that not personalized
and we still rely on them almost
completely so that's my little my little
spiel there it's related to this topic
but I do think that the onus is not just
on the tech world we talk about a lot
especially here point but the education
the medical system are old they're
inflexible this idea that technology
would somehow be positively disruptive
to them has not happened putting a book
on an iPad is not disruptive technology
that's like obvious use of the evolution
of media we could do more and and I hope
we will that's really important yeah
yeah I love it
I love it good clap I'm so happy that
you highlighted education and healthcare
as these parts of kind of a three you
could say as a as a tripod of the
importance to to this matter at hand and
as you were illustrating I was thinking
like well what if teachers actually knew
like yes if Sarah has the best working
memory johnny has the best emotional
regulation I was just thinking like
who's best at looking at the other kids
and the eyes and feeling what they're
feeling emotion I'd be that'd be so cool
if we were and this is what a lot of
what is going on so you were you were
listing anxiety depression PTSD ADHD all
even Alzheimer's Parkinson's so Adam has
neuro scape an amazing lab here in at
UCSF in San Francisco and you're
building out amazing ways to tackle some
of these challenges and that's also
going to with Achille yes yeah so teach
us about this because it's I way prefer
talking about this topic than the one we
just finished talking about I'm an
optimist if any of you know me I mean I
love thinking about a positive future
how we could use technology in a really
healthy way it's what I spend 95% of my
life doing I think it's important to put
in the context of what we just you know
disgust of why it's so needed right now
on a global level but what's more fun
for me to discuss and to talk about is
how do we fix this where do we go
forward from here and so I have a lot of
entities that I'm involved in but we all
they all do the same thing whether it's
a venture fund or companies or my Center
at UCSF it's all how do we invent create
new technologies to help us better
understand the human brain in a more
real-world manner and to improve its
function look closer you know a whole
you know host of domains that we've been
talking about and so you know this was
not where I started so when I back in
1990 when I was a grad student in
Manhattan I was an MD PhD student so as
a as a medical professional mineralogist
the patients I saw the most were people
with Alzheimer's disease as a scientist
I'm a neuroscientist and I always had
been as many of us in my field studying
how the brain works that's most what
most neuroscientists do ten years ago I
just I got frustrated with that it's not
why did an MD PhD in the first place I
want to actually help people and I don't
want to help people in some abstract way
that's something I discover when I'm 20
is used when like I'm 80 I want to do it
like while I'm alive and healthy and can
see those things and be a part of it the
translational yeah the translation of
neuroscience into real-world benefits
and the only way we've really done that
is neuroscientists mostly there's small
other exceptions is through molecules
right that is like the vast you know
giant ocean liner that we've created to
help fix the brain is to give molecule
small molecules we call pharmaceuticals
we call them drugs chemicals all the
same thing LSD we put them in that's
that's a whole whole of this story we
put them in our mouths they go to our
brains in general they have very non
selective effects and in my world of
attention as I described in memory and
aging they don't work very well at all
the drugs that we use to treat
Alzheimer's disease don't help some
people at all so other people they help
modestly we know the challenges with
attention deficits and children as well
and so I was thinking do we have another
approach and I became inspired by two
things first a literature so I'm backing
up this 2008 10 years ago because it
doesn't make sense if I just jump to
what we're doing today I was inspired by
two things first there was a literature
coming out at the time that videogames
consumer video games like Call of Duty
the most controversial of all video
games first-person shooter games if you
study them in young people that play
them what you find is that their
cognitive control abilities their
attention the distraction resistance
their working memory their task
switching is so off the charts compared
to children kids in their school that
don't play these games that's right
sometimes you can't even use the same
tests it's really fascinating and I was
like huh that's that's interesting right
because there's something there and
these games were not designed for this
so I don't like it quickly cuz I used to
please get out of those games and a lot
of my friends you know the Halos the
Call of Duty's etc there's so much
nuance that we typically forget about
there's an array let's save a dozen Max
and then you study every single square
foot of these maps
thus the locations the spawn locations
you study the different weaponry that
you can use in the different attachments
and there's of course the when someone's
trying to bother you from while you're
playing with your teammates you're
focused on the game because your team's
relying on you you have to make
call-outs you're talking and interacting
with the team it's some fascinating
things resource management there's so
many cool some of the aspects of games
that were that at least a lot of the
early researchers and I didn't do this
research were really latched on to the
rapid switching that occurs and and the
need for very focused attention but also
keeping broad it broad attention at the
same time so there were elements that
were hypothesized as active ingredients
and why this occurred at all I was also
interested I started getting interested
you know where we live and
all not just videogames but meditation
and really ancient practices that lots
of data have was being generated that
help our brain function and so you know
the idea behind this is is like one of
the most foundational neuroscience
discoveries of our time is that the
brain is plastic that it will respond
and modify itself in response to
experience so I think of you know
meditation and therapy and even
education as experiential treatments
they changed the brain because they
engage it in a certain experience and
then if that engagement is repetitive
and rewarded the brain changes I might
not change in a good way it doesn't have
any morality any directionality it just
changes in response to the experience
that experience could be so bad that it
could detrimental impact the function of
your brain for the rest of your life
one experience we call that
post-traumatic stress disorder
one event not a chemical not shrapnel
seeing something can impact your brain
function forever
because of this plasticity phenomena so
we know it's powerful that's not in
question no neuroscientist questions
that the idea is how do we create
experiences that maximally harness the
brain in a positive direction to try to
improve these abilities that are not
being helped in my mind by our current
education system or our medical system
and so with those two pieces I came up
with the idea of building a video game a
video game that was an experience that
of course all video games are an
experience it is an experiential
treatment whether you want it to be or
not but the video games have this really
interesting advantage over things like
traditional meditation or therapy or
music training or classroom education in
that they can be designed in a way
that's reproducibly delivered so you go
to a meditation class and depending on
the context or your teacher in
particular you may or may not have the
right experience and that has led to a
lot of problems for these
using practices in terms of their
accessibility to people that might not
have that you know that access to that
teacher also it's very hard to perform
randomized control trials when what
you're delivering is not consistently
delivered and those fields as impressive
as they are have to suffer for it suffer
to the degree that you don't see
meditation being prescribed like you see
adderall or even physical exercise and
so to put this together the ability of
our software to create a closed-loop
system this is like the most common word
I use nowadays because I put everything
that I do is related to closed loop so a
closed loop means that you could create
a piece of software that records your
performance ideally your physiology
would know you in a deeper way than
anything possibly could
looking at your emotional responses your
facial expressions your heart rate your
brain activity use that data to create a
perfectly tailored experience to
challenge you appropriately in just the
perfect way and to reward you in such a
manner that you're deeply engaged that
plasticity changes your brain and
improves your performance that was the
idea and so with that foundation which
is still the foundation of everything I
do we created a video game with friends
of mine at LucasArts called neuro racer
my friend Matt Omer Nick who is a chief
creative officer at Lucas and that game
went on we did numerous research studies
on it we published our results in the
journal Nature in 2013 which is you know
as good as it gets for us scientists was
on the cover of the journal and what we
showed there is that we could take a
group of healthy older adults have them
play this closed-loop video game that
actually challenged their abilities to
resolve interference across multiple
domains and what we showed was that we
can improve their sustained attention
and their working memory on tasks
outside of the game with multiple
control groups and neural recordings
during gameplay to show mechanistically
what was changing in their brain that
led to these benefits out of the game
that's what we showed 2013
and so that's really changed the lives
for myself and and a lot of other people
I know there are people here from
Achille which grew out of nur erasers
shoutout yeah yeah Achille people have
to know so with so now we're 2013 so
that was 2008 2013 2013 with that
publication you know it had more web
impressions than anything like in UCSF
history at the time I think 60,000 web
impressions just in the first day it's
still one of the most cited papers in
nature in the last decade I mean it was
a big deal because it really hit a sweet
spot right it was video games it was
positive data on older adults and
multitasking it had a lot of keywords in
there and you know it's a feel-good
story which you know it seems to be hard
to come by these days
so with that event my laboratory
converted into a research center it just
got so big over time that were now neuro
scape a center so it was Ghazali lab now
we've become bigger than that we have a
whole team of faculty we have a
technology program that first patent was
now followed up by eight more of other
closed-loop technologies and that patent
which I invented UCSF owns we licensed
to a company we created called the Kelly
interactive with my friend Matt Omer
Nick from LucasArts and an adventure
group in Boston called pure tech and so
Achille licensed that technology and is
now over the last eight years created a
way better game higher levels of art
music story rewards cycles usability
cloud support server analytical
everything elevated turning that game
into what we now call digital medicine
so the idea is that we can use this
closed-loop experience to improve
abilities of the mind to a level that we
could Knob not achieve with any molecule
because we don't have the targeting or
the personalization and so that's what's
going on now Achille isn't taking that
technology all the way into into
people's lives we could talk about that
more
and neuro scape is essentially an
incubator we build new technologies
using these principles that we talked
about we don't build products we build
prototypes we're right here at Mission
Bay and then we do deep dive research
studies to see if we have a signal that
something important is going on here if
so then we move it out into the world of
Industry to turn it into products that's
a start I love it Adam so there was you
know something that you started hinting
at there with having the closed loop
where you're actually measuring the
results translationally with working
memory sustained attention and I love
hearing about this strains this one just
moved towards towards digital medicine I
love it you're no you and we'll get to
this but you literally we're talking
about once FDA approves prescribing
video games as solutions to instead of
these you called it a job sledgehammer
molecules yeah yeah you you you started
hinting at the word flow your get you're
challenging people your algorithms
challenged people to their peak of their
cognitive abilities so you when they're
struggling with the task you take the
challenge level down a bit when they're
succeeding too much you up the challenge
level and you get them to this deep
state of flow with the with the
objective that they're competing and
then that translates out to the real
world
yeah so teach us about I love that word
flow and I want to know what you think
about that connection and then also now
where it's being applied and okay yeah
so you know the the video game world
knows the term flow well it's something
that's used a lot my colleagues that are
game designers and developers and it's
one that we don't use as much in
cognitive neuroscience but it's a clear
phenomena when you engage personally
I've experienced it it is what we do try
to achieve by creating challenges that
are not so difficult that you're
frustrated in a bad
and it not so easy that you're bored you
can create and also coupled with you
know tightly integrated reward cycles it
is it's not trivial on how to create
this but we believe it's possible to do
I mean athletes dancers you know
professional surfer people that engage
in high level activities and take it to
an extreme you know live in this world
of flow and it's uh you know it's its
own form of a drug in a way but we also
believe it is the way that plasticity is
maximally harnessed in this state and
one of the things that we're pursuing is
how do we create that state as deeply
and as excessively as possible using
closed loop algorithms my view so most
of our games including like Achilles is
really responding to your performance
metrics in real time where we're going
with this is what we call multimodal
biosensing which is one of our divisions
at neuro scape to see how many signals
we could measure about a person in the
moment and then integrate it using
machine learning algorithms to then
understand the state of an individual in
a much much deeper way than we ever have
before if that data can then be used to
create an environment and we've gotten
more sophisticated on our environments
so a lot of our recent development is
using virtual reality and when I say
that I don't just mean a head-mounted
display I mean full sensory stimulation
ideally olfactory visual auditory
tactile stimulation where you have this
very very complex loop of all this data
about you flowing into a software system
that knows how to interpret that data
not trivial and then feed back an
environment that is constantly and
dynamically adjusting to you to create
this state that allows you to adjust all
these complex aspects of your thinking
this is our AI vision as I always say AI
for H AI artificial intelligence for
human intelligence that's where I think
this type of these types of algorithms
should go so that's you know a future
vision that I described to you
that is what we're working towards but
not what we do right now is we're
working on the pieces of it so that's
that's where we're heading but most of
our algorithms right now are really
adjusting to heart rate or to
performance we're starting to feed brain
signals into the algorithm but this once
we achieve this level then we really
will I believe have digital medicines
that outperform almost anything that
we've ever used before and then you just
just quick just teach us about where cuz
you you where is this meant yeah Health
application happening all right so what
Achille is doing so I described neuro
scape I think you got a pretty good view
of what we do here at UCSF Achille is a
health care company we're a medical
device company that largely is focusing
on that very first technology that neuro
research technology that now has been
developed to a much higher level and
then taking that through multiple
clinical trials Achille is a very unique
tech company and that we have no revenue
because we will not have any products
until we have FDA approval so we're
working to create a new type of medicine
that reaches the same level of approval
and rigor that drugs do right now that's
basically the bar that will holding
ourselves to we have over a dozen
clinical trials on many many different
conditions some of them are very early
like the work we're doing in traumatic
brain injury and PTSD some are further
along like autism and depression and
multiple sclerosis we also have early
work in Alzheimer's and Parkinson's many
many studies going on the study that's
most advanced the research is our work
on ADHD so pediatric ADHD is a was our
first main target lots of reasons why
that should be the case I'm happy to
dive into that if you're interested in
the Q & A but we completed a phase three
trial that's the type of research study
that you do that's multi-site
double-blind randomized control that you
do right before you submit to the FDA to
get approval for clearance of a drug or
a device that study was performed that
took multiple years over
300 children involved in that study I
think over 15 sites that study was
successful we were successfully able to
improve attention in these children
beyond a placebo control group that
played a different game that study has
now been submitted to the FDA to get
approval to have this type of digital
medicine prescribed by physicians as the
first non drug treatment for ADHD and we
expect and really hope that that will
happen in 2019 so we're very close to
that so it'll be the first non drug
treatment for ADHD the first of first
prescribed old video game and the first
of a new category of medicine of digital
medicine I always like to think of this
that we have pharmaceutical medicines
that deliver molecular treatments a
digital medicine delivers an
experiential treatment I love it right
the the treatment is the experience the
video game is essentially like our pill
it's how we deliver the experience you
in a way that's tasty and engaging and
sustainable but it's the experience that
changes your brain because of its
plasticity mmm this also makes me want
to talk about psychedelics so the
molecules that deliver experiences that
are incredible Adam all right this has
been great I want to just do a couple
rapid-fire things on the way just before
Q&A rapid fire with jazz ventures jazz
partners you guys are investing in tons
of neuroscience related to technical
Oakman society what are some of your
favorite applications of neuro tech to
society right now and what are you most
looking forward to in that yes so along
the way I realized and and friends of
mine that we you know I couldn't do
everything with this company or with
neuro escapes so started a venture fund
with friends called jazz venture
partners we're now on our second fund
and we invest in technology for human
performance improvement and quality
improvement you know things as diverse
is using virtual reality to help people
with certain impairments improve their
function brain stimulation devices to
help accelerate learning
that's something that we do at ucsf as
well you know it's we we invest in
companies in the medical domain like
Achille jazz is a big investor in
Achille but also an accelerated learning
even like validated wellness products so
where I go with the technology that we
created a neuro scape might not be
completely healthcare we're also
interested in moving things into the
education domain we recently completed a
study probably the biggest ever of 1200
is neuro scape 1208 to 12 year olds
around the bay area using our assessment
tools to understand their cognitive
abilities remember I said we don't
assess cognition and children unless we
think they have a developmental
Challenger or some learning disability
this is healthy children on the steering
their cognition and then after school
playing select games to see if we could
push on those levers to optimize them
right so it would be one thing if we
just assess children's cognition and
then you're like you're stuck over here
this is your fate that's not how we view
it at all we assess the cognition just
not to isolate or marginalize or just
classify but to use that as the building
blocks to have actionable tools to help
improve those abilities so some of our
products and and some of what jazz
invests in and what neuro scape makes
will go more educational so Achille as a
prescription treatment is just one
pathway and one company this is
simulation so when to be a simulation if
I didn't ask you okay are we in a
simulation from some perspectives we are
but you know I think that without even
reaching outside of the normal construct
that we've come to experience it's
already mystical and magical enough so
I'm happy believing in reality for
however we define Matt and I don't feel
that we need to be in a computer game to
feel challenged you're leveling up quite
quickly Adam and what do you think's the
most beautiful thing in the world nature
I love nature
I grew up in New York City so nature to
me was like concrete and brick which is
pretty you know but I discovered it when
I was in my late 20s and changed my
entire life I just got back from three
weeks in New Zealand just completely
immersed in the natural world and you
know I think that there's so much
healing could go on there as well so
yeah yeah yeah those he has videos of
him bungee jumping and skydiving and all
this kind of crazy awesome stuff all
right this was super fun Adam thank you
for joining us on simulation everyone
thank you for attending what Q&A
happened now thank you
[Applause]
[Music]